and it's just getting worse right
banking i know like republican political
operatives in arizona wells fargo has
just shut out yeah they at least had the
grace to allow these people to withdraw
their money before just closing the
accounts but like pretty soon like we
are moving this way social credit
systems right like
we thought that uh helping china
industrialize would make them more like
us we thought it would turn them into a
liberal democracy no actually it's
our society is becoming remarkably a lot
more like china yeah a sort of oligarchy
controlled by a few people um obviously
our version looks different but i think
they're using big tech i think they're
using the university they're using
corporations ngos ford foundation all
this stuff it's it's really part of this
web that just kind of swims left
so i want to talk about the big tech
thing you've been very
big on the big tech thing and what do we
do this is the perfect blend of like
okay libertarian principles free market
all of that but society seems to be
crumbling under algorithms
what do we do
we got to reign in big tech we just have
to i think five years ago you know
people weren't ready for this um the big
tech companies actually were less
abusive five years they've grown a lot
like things have changed and this is
what i mean you need people in
leadership uh people in office who are
tracking these changes and who can
intervene
i think i'm a pro market guy you know
peter invested in facebook that's
fantastic we want companies that we
invest in to become huge and successful
but at a certain point when companies
become more powerful than most
governments
when a handful of corporations come to
dominate and control the flow of
information in society i think we can
afford to treat them differently
than you might trade a bakery or a hair
salon
and so i really just worry about
you know google being able to swing an
election
at least when facebook rips the hunter
biden story off the internet two or
three weeks before the election which is
complete crap and they shouldn't be
allowed to do it
but when they did that people noticed
and you know you have the streisand
effect sort of thing where it's this
discussion we can talk about it and at
least the censorship was transparent but
with google they can change their search
algorithms to you know if they're subtle
enough i think you could change it a
meaningful amount suppress this
information about trump boost this
information about biden
and all of a sudden
you know do you really live in a free
country anymore
and so i think we um i think we have to
pay attention to this conservatives
focus a lot on censorship and i think we
should because conservatives really are
censored they ripped president trump off
facebook and twitter while he was
president yeah meanwhile taliban
commanders you know have blue check
marks yeah and so this is crazy and
censorship is a huge problem and i think
you know you can repeal section 230 and
you can treat the the platforms as
common carriers which i think we should
do
but i think the problems with big tech
are a lot deeper
too i worry a lot about like targeted
advertising you know and you just saw
um the study that came out last week
that showed how bad instagram is
for teenagers yeah especially teenage
women like they're mentioning it's like
surprise surprise everyone's pretending
they're shocked oh my god i can't we
knew this right you knew this yeah and
it's just the endless feed and then you
hoover up all this data about people and
use it in pretty predatory ways um sort
of subterranean you're hacking their
psychology like these companies employ
psychologists on staff as well as
software designers to get people hooked
on the products to to get ever more data
to serve them ever more targeted ads and
i think we shouldn't be doing that at
least for teenagers like we shouldn't be
allowing facebook to advertise to kids
right now in some ways
though like i know we can do things and
let's say you get into the senate and we
have the hearings and everyone's seen
the hearings and even guys that i like
at the hearings those are ted cruz
but they're brutal no matter what
because even when there's a nice moment
when rand paul really you know gets jack
at twitter or ted cruz does you know
really gets somebody caught in a lie
nothing ever changes so is it possible
that we've now been manipulated this is
sort of my like matrix version of this
we've been manipulated in so many ways
now for for enough years that
no matter what you could do as part of
the government it would be like yeah you
know dropping a barrel i agree that's a
risk but i think that's uh to just
conclude that is to give up
and so i don't i think there's at least
still a really good chance you can do a
lot um
maybe not to start you know one senator
can't really unilaterally pass a bill
right but i think uh
i'm gonna get in there and make so much
noise and actually run effective
hearings and like i think i really do
know what to do with these companies
like josh hawley senator holly has shown
a lot of leadership on this and if you
get a core group five or six people like
that you get the ball rolling it may
take some time but i think we actually
can make meaningful progress here
because i think also big tech is just
going to get bigger and bigger right
these structural monopolies they just
become
ever more profitable like unless we rein
them in they're just going to take over
more and more ground
especially now that like they're not
even private companies right like
facebook is working with the biden
administration to decide what is coveted
misinformation yeah jen saki says
facebook pulled us off and facebook you
know
like a good boy pulls it off yeah and
that's we really like great things for
facebook that's why
of course they're a private company they
can make their own decisions of course
we have a giant ftc you know under
linocon right uh that we're that we're
gonna use as a giant threat to make you
comply
i think this stuff is really dangerous i
don't think we can afford to give up
you know possibly these companies are
too big and powerful possibly they'll
just do everything they can to make sure
that people like me don't get elected um
but it's a risk we have to take yeah
because otherwise we're throwing in the
towel when i heard you speak a couple
weeks ago uh somebody asked you
something about this and basically you
that was your answer and then you said
at the end like you were like well what
are they gonna do kill me and everyone
kind of got quiet for a second but it's
like
yeah but it's like who knows what these
people could what they could do i'm not
saying they're coming to kill you but
like just the way they can manipulate
and make everybody hate everybody and
again after what i saw what they did to
larry elder and when i would google his
name after i'd be at rallies where there
was so much love so much support and
every single article in google it was
like i think 12 out of the 15 on the
first page hit piece hit piece hit piece
hit piece right and it's like that's a
it's a form it's like a digital
assassination right yeah no i i mean i
think it'll get really ugly i do
but i think and you know i think social
media is really flawed like maybe the
world isn't instantly
uh shouldn't be instantly connected you
know so you can outrage mobs in london
because you know some some something
happened in the us like that's actually
a really weird phenomenon this hyper
connectivity i don't think that's going
away i don't think we can or necessarily
even should make that go away but i do
think like nope super powerful
multinational corporations shouldn't
have the power and the ability to swing
an election and i don't think you know
past a certain point past a certain
market cap or once you have 100 million
users on your platform or whatever i
think you're a common carrier and the
phone company can't you know
discriminate against us because we have
political views and so facebook
shouldn't be able to do it either to me
that's like the bare minimum that we
need to do um you mean alex jones should
be entitled to a phone my gosh
yeah imagine and it's just getting worse
right banking i know like republican
political operatives in arizona wells
fargo has just shut out yeah they at
least had the grace to allow these
people to withdraw their money before
just closing the accounts but like
pretty soon like we are moving this way
social credit systems right like we
thought that uh helping china
industrialize would make them more like
us we thought it would turn them into a
liberal democracy no actually it's
our society's becoming remarkably a lot
more like china yeah a sort of oligarchy
controlled by a few people
obviously our version looks different
but i think they're using big tech i
think they're using the university
they're using corporations ngos ford
foundation all this stuff it's it's
really part of this web that just kind
of swims left do you want to seize their
money i think jd vance said generally
yeah great yeah like basically they're
funding all these things that are
destroying america yeah and let's take
the money at least let's tax them
because they're not a real non-profit
there's huge non-profit left-wing
non-profit abuse in this country yeah um
all right so if if it's not too late to
do something about big tech does it feel
at least like there was like this slow
push
and then suddenly it became very rapid
where right now it feels like every day
we wake up and it's like there's some
other crazy thing happening whether it's
someone being banned or the credit card
stuff that you're talking about or
something related to speech or something
where it seems like and everything we
haven't we've barely talked about covid
where it's just like every day there's
some other crazy thing happens and it
feels like the algorithm is feeding it
to us like it doesn't feel organic to me
anymore when i wake up every morning and
there's just some you know and on
twitter experts say experts already
mentioned that that something else is
fueling like the craziness here hard to
know i mean i agree with you it's just
getting crazier and crazier and it feels
like a one-way ratchet how much is
intentional and manipulated and you know
designed for some effect versus just
this is the crazy consequence of the
world we live in it's very stagnant we
have all eric weinstein talks about
embedded growth obligations right like
we have all these uh these expectations
that things just get better and better
in our society
but they actually don't like these
institutions broke a long time ago but
people i think are a little bit behind
the curve and realizing it and so i
think we're careening off the cliff here
there is something you know there's
something very weird about how um how
gen x has gotten um
you know
has been sort of sidelined by the
boomers for so long yeah and then the
you know the rap on us um is always that
we're you know we're too uh
too young or too old
right and so we were you know in the 90s
when gen x was starting the tech
companies
we were seen as too young we needed
adult supervision we needed the baby
boomers to run the companies and that's
and almost every gen x
of founder and some exceptions but
overwhelmingly the boomers took over the
companies there was a version that's
with yahoo and ebay
netscape
even google which was the biggest of the
gen x companies um uh you got a 10-year
period where eric schmidt the baby
boomer took over
uh took over google whereas you know the
boomer companies apple
microsoft um
uh amazon
um
microsoft and amazon amazon were just
same people got to run the whole time
and then you know apple's a little bit
more chaotic facebook millennial company
they got to run it gen x uh not so much
do you think that i think i think one
can and and tech is like meritocratic
it's not supposed to be about right
culture and voting and stuff like this
um
and then i think um i think on a on a
political level it's striking how
underrepresented we are
uh you know um uh uh 2020
should be should be a prime year for a
gen x presidential candidate on the
democratic side someone born between
1965
and 1980 and i challenge you to name me
a single plausible
gen x uh democrat
don't pick a loser like cory booker
right i mean that's the thing well i
think there's several reasons for that
on the democratic side but they've gone
off so deep and it's somehow the boomers
they're they're more of them and so they
they they look like it's it's truth in
numbers and it's the baby boomer bubble
in a way has always been that the
numbers make it right that if you have a
lot of people it's true
and that's kind of what worked and so
you know
the boomers were this unusually big
generation and it was just about them
it's just about getting consensus and
then you could overwhelm things and
that's that's what you had to do
and i think that's
that's sort of coming to an end slowly i
wonder do you think there's also just
the flat out technological component to
this that we in gen x were the last
generation that grew up without all of
this tech so i don't know what the exact
connection is but i remember
being in college i think my freshman
year i remember some kid down the
hallway screaming i'm on the internet
and i went into his room i've told the
story a couple times i went into his
room and it said yankees three royals
one and it had two pictures of the logos
and i swear on my life i remember
thinking this is the stupidest thing
i've ever seen like we did not grow up
with the phones in our pockets we didn't
grow up connected all those things so it
almost seems to me there's some
connection to that where then the
millennials came in they were so
connected to all of this then the media
because the media wants clicks and
everything paid so much attention to
them that that maybe pushed out gen x a
little bit more do you think there's i'm
just i'm just doing this you know like
sort of cultural history it's always
many variables
super over determined i i do think
there's
there's um
there's something about the millennial
vibe that feels
more conformist yeah and gen x feels
less conformist and and so uh and so one
of the
you know good and bad things about being
overly connected overly technologically
connected is you know you get to get to
know the score right away you get the
answer right away you know you're
supposed to be scared of climate change
right away um and that's good if it's
true
it's bad if it's a shortcut and so our
generation you could say was the last
one where that didn't take shortcuts and
most the time you the boomers learned to
take shortcuts we you know we didn't
take as many shortcuts i like that
millennials
know to take all the shortcuts and um
it's a good idea to take shortcuts in a
world where nobody takes shortcuts
um in a world where everybody takes
shortcuts
um you know you have to actually figure
out maybe the shortcut isn't going to
work and you're actually better off
figuring out the other thing yeah i
think oh i love it so so one way to
frame this would be in the boomer era
um
the boomers who figured out how to take
shortcuts so the shortcut in politics
is i'm not going to figure out what i
think about the issues i'm going to look
at the polls
and uh and the pollster is the one who's
really running for president and we're
just listening to the pollster and that
was that was an effective boomer
technique for many years that you just
look at the polls and if you were if you
had a better pollster you could more
quickly get to where the puck was going
where the crowd was going and you didn't
need to think you didn't waste time
thinking about stuff and so in a world
where very few people are doing it
that could be a very good strategy
by the time you get to the something
like the millennials where everyone's
been trained to do shortcuts
that it somehow doesn't quite work
it vaguely maps onto the tracking
because you can think of tracking in
school tracking professionally is a way
to it's like a shortcut to a successful
career
and so the baby boomers who stayed on
track did quite well so you didn't you
know tune in and drop out in the late
60s and just went to law school and you
became a part of the law firm
that kind of tracks worked
by the time we get to the millennials
they know all the tracks you're supposed
to do tracks work less well when
everybody knows them everyone's doing
the same thing so it has
there's sort of there are these
similarities between the millennials and
the boomers but
the lesson
they're they're um they're really
different in practice and it's working
really differently so the things that
would have worked perfectly for you as a
boomer are deadly if you're a millennial
so you mentioned some i mean these are
big name schools mit harvard you are
educate educated in biology and you're
working with algorithms all these things
google finds you after you do this
competition
so
sort of to lay out how this whole thing
got written and why you did it
first you're working at google for a
while and then they started sending you
guys not just you but people to
diversity training is that correct right
okay so can you explain what diversity
training is
yeah it's
kind of complicated because there's
multiple different
programs but
uh it's often talking about
how you know we have fifty percent of
people in the population are women but
at google we only have 20
and so they discuss all of the sexism
that's happening
and how that's holding back women in
general
and
uh then they also have stuff about
racism and all these other unconscious
biases because you know we don't really
see anything like oh you're a woman
therefore you can't code there's never
these explicit forms of bias that we see
and so and we haven't really been able
to measure
x like actual bias at google so we just
assume that there's some sort of
low-level bias that's happening
and you know it's
always really impossible to measure
but so they these programs go over that
they go over microaggressions
and
white male privilege
and then discuss how we can
make the workplace better for women
and how we can get more women on our
teams basically yeah now uh you don't
have anything against women do you isn't
that something i need to know that james
damore thinks about women uh before we
go any further i i definitely like women
i i had women on my team and i you know
i treated them well yeah i i mean i
discussed a lot of these issues with
them and they actually largely agreed
and they helped me discuss you know okay
on average women are say more
cooperative and how can we change the
workplace so it's not just you know some
alpha male that
owns a project and gets promoted and
it's actually people working in teams
and all of them getting uh recognized
yeah so it's interesting to me because i
obviously have a small business here
most of my jobs in my life have been odd
jobs or doing stand-up things like that
i've never worked for a giant
corporation like google before and it's
funny because when you talk about
well 50 of the population is female and
google only has 20 percent it's almost
like well how is that an issue for the
average employee at google now the
microaggressions and that other stuff i
can see why if you buy that that stuff
is legit if they're hr people buy that
stuff legit i can see why they'd sit
down with employees and talk about that
but to talk about the 50
of women in the population and we only
have 20 here isn't that something for hr
to deal with what does that have to do
with
bringing in software engineers and
talking to them about that
yeah i think google just has a long
history of you know the whole don't be
evil and you know we make a ton of money
through ads therefore we feel sort of
guilty and we have to help the world in
general so we do a lot of
philanthropy and
they're really big on being allies
for these groups
and just outreach in general yeah if it
makes you feel better they're not making
much money on us because they don't
monetize anything and i can't our video
i just told you before we started our
video from this morning from this
morning with phil defranco who has
almost 6 million subscribers who's one
of the first youtube creators uh around
was demonetized this morning it's like
so but i do want to talk to you a little
bit about the algorithm but let's let's
keep going with your story okay so you
go to these these meetings uh obviously
you're having a bit of an ideological
difference
in terms of what you think versus what
they're pushing on you uh they asked for
your feedback correct after these things
so can you tell me about that yes uh in
all of our meetings and programs in
general uh we're usually very open and
we ask for feedback in how we can
improve these
and so i i wrote this document because i
really wanted to put my thoughts down
and so i sent it to them and they looked
at it but they because it's a google doc
so i could actually see that they looked
at it and read through it but they just
never did anything and this happened
multiple times i went to multiple
programs and they just ignored it every
time yeah so to be clear when you say
program so you sent it to a they have
several diversity
groups right so you sent it to several
different groups what are some of the
groups uh so one of them was about
unbiasing
and another was your journey towards
you know rethinking race
so those are
several of them that i went to
and yeah this is and we're just ignoring
yeah you saw that they were open but you
were just annoyed so so just to be clear
you write this in response because they
want feedback that's actually nice to
hear that companies want feedback i keep
trying to get them on the phone with me
to discuss some of the problems that i'm
having with youtube that that seems to
be kind of difficult but you write this
in response which is sort of what
they're asking for they're asking for
your feedback now you are a a scary uh
white male and you're tall
so that's got to be working against it
you do
then you submit this to several of these
diversity groups who ignore you then you
submitted it to one particular one and
that's where this really took off so so
which one was that yeah so after a month
of uh actually sending it to
individual people and some smaller email
lists and actually getting some good
feedback that wasn't you know this
emotional outrage
i wait that's interesting let's not jump
past that so first you're you are
getting some feedback within the company
and people are basically
yeah basically okay
half the people would be just like yes i
agree totally
and then the other half would disagree
on certain points and they say oh are
you sure that this is happening and
especially
if you're progressive then you often
don't even see a progressive echo
chamber because you just see oh yeah
that's how things should be
and what's wrong with all this
and oh are you sure that people would
actually be shamed for saying these
things
you know and because you think that that
system or that world view is so complete
or something it's hard for them to
imagine which is exactly what an echo
chamber is
and so that was all fine but then uh i
was sent it to this one email list
called skeptics so i thought you know
skeptics would be rational and they'd be
able to
point out holes in my argument because
honestly the whole time i was just i
want to be wrong because if i'm right
then there's something bad happening
right please tell me how i'm wrong
and that's not really what the response
was it was just this is crap what are
you doing
and it eventually just exploded without
within the company yeah all right so to
be clear so the skeptic group which is
the group that should be skeptical of
all facts and opinions and all that you
send it to them but then how within that
so now you start getting some feedback
on it how within that group did this
then get to the larger world and that's
when all hell broke loose yeah uh so
some of the
people would start sending emails to say
my upper management and hr
demanding that i'd be fired or something
and so
hr and uh some of the higher level execs
started sending out mass emails saying
oh yes we know about this document don't
worry you know it's harmful don't look
at it this is not what google stands for
which obviously you know if you tell
someone that this is harmful they're
gonna just look at it it's harmful don't
look at it that's what executives were
saying i mean that's it
and
also there were a ton of memes within
the company just
talking about you know how horrible this
was
and just blasting me as a person
[Music]
now was there any retribution on those
people we'll get to you actually getting
fired and called into the office but you
as far as everything that i read in this
document which i did read you didn't
attack anyone personally you go out of
your way not to stereotype people can
argue with you know your conclusions or
all that but you were being attacked
personally by people then within the
company was there any retribution from
the on to those people no not that i
know of there was even someone that
emailed directly saying you are a
terrible person you're a misogynist i'm
going to like hunt you down
until
you're fired or i'm fired
like send this to hr i don't care which
means that maybe he knows that hr isn't
really going to do anything yeah
and so i sent it to hr but so you didn't
send me hr did they even respond they
said oh yeah work from home
but i told you to work from home yeah so
j i just i think it's so important to
repeat some of this stuff you wrote this
in response to being taken to a place
where they wanted your feedback now they
happen to not like your feedback okay
then you were being threatened in a way
by other employees and being attacked
online with the memes and all that stuff
again while you're still an employee
there and hr tells you to work from home
yeah
and you have no evidence that they
contacted this person at all
i i honestly don't know and i mean there
were many people that started attacking
me and it was mostly public attacks
because you know most people aren't
really courageous enough to send me an
email like that right and they just want
to show other people oh look how great i
am i
got offended by this and let's all band
together and punch nazis yeah yeah yes
right uh virtue signaling right but yeah
the industry term for that okay so then
now you're be you are being attacked
personally you're being told by hr to
stay home
now did you get a call or an email how
did you end up in an office where they
said
you're out of here buddy
uh yeah so i
they eventually just called me monday
night and
said
james you've been terminated for
perpetuating gender stereotypes
and then you know i tried to discuss it
with them but they didn't have any of
that they did this on the phone yeah
they didn't even have you come into the
office and tell you face-to-face and
they were probably afraid that i would
just you know have some outburst or
something well you seem very violent and
scary i mean i've never seen a more
soft-spoken you know
slim uh you know you don't strike me as
someone that's going to hurt anybody but
even i mean the sort of cowardice of
that is is actually kind of incredible
so okay so then you get fired now this
is after it had gone public obviously so
the stories were all over the place at
this point
um
did you try to plead your case i mean
did you say this is crazy i was just
doing actually the same thing that
you're asking everyone else to do you
just don't happen to like my opinions
yeah i tried to
but
obviously
it didn't have any effect yeah
um
is there a legal issue there that you
know of i'm assuming every lawyer and
their cousin is out to talk to you these
days about uh
lawsuits and all that so i
even before they fired me i made a claim
to the national labor relations board
because what this is is i was making
concerted uh effort with multiple other
employees that agreed with me to improve
our working conditions so you know i
pointed out multiple ways in which there
was harassment in the workplace and that
there was illegal
uh discrimination in our hiring
practices yeah can you give me an
example of that of the legal
discrimination yeah yeah so
as far as i know and according to our
internal policies you can't use
someone's protected status so their age
race or gender
when you're determining hiring or other
employment critical situations
so and but we do
in these you know we treat different
candidates differently and then if
someone is going up for promotion
they may be treated differently so
there's a lot of small things that we're
doing they may be treated differently in
a positive way if they're one of those
protected it's just worth actually
saying the full sentence because i think
people get people are so confused by
what's going on these days that
everything is upside down yeah
um
so okay so you contact them and then
where are you at in terms of any legal
stuff right now as much as you can tell
me all right yeah so we've filed the
claim
and so they're investigating right now
and we are also looking for other
googlers that have had similar treatment
and we've gotten multiple responses for
that
so there have been multiple cases in the
past where say someone and like i'm of
course four gay rights but someone just
didn't want to go to gay pride parade
and they got fired for that it's like
that's a little too that's literally
true yeah
so someone at google just said i don't
want to go to the gay pride parade yeah
and they got fired for that
at least according to them we have to
look into it more but
and there have been multiple cases like
that where if you don't
agree with the progressive ideology then
you're then you're discriminated against
before i do anything else can you just
tell me a little bit about how and why
you created rumble because this is not
something that just magically appeared
out of nowhere a year ago you've been
working on this thing for a long time
no i have for sure so i've i've actually
been in this space for
two decades now i started uh
it was like 2001 so yeah exactly two
decades and i remember it was about
2005. i had one of my friends send me an
icq message or an msn messenger message
and they're like hey check this site out
and it was youtube and at the time my
friend owned like the top 50 website on
the internet
uh in video
and he's like these guys are gonna crush
me they're they're well funded i got
nothing i won't be able to keep up with
the funding and they're gonna win and
you know fast forward two years youtube
sucks up all the oxygen in the room
google buys them google puts them into
the search engine and uh they end up
being the de facto video platform
on the internet uh post 2007 2008 and
kind of monopolized the entire not kinda
they monopolize the entire video sphere
uh online
so it puts all of us out of business
that own any video sites or small sites
were you know no longer existing and
then it wasn't until about 2010 where i
started seeing
a a shift change uh
a real change in the way youtube was uh
doing things they introduced
multi-channel networks they introduced
uh
you know a lot of preferencing on big
corporations and icons so it was about
it took me till about 2013 where i said
you know it's time to get back into this
space it really seems to me that uh that
the incumbent platform youtube at the
time is starting to really de-prioritize
the small creator and really prioritize
those multi-channel networks big
influencers uh large brands large
corporations and the our aunts and our
uncles and our friends and family no
longer really had any kind of space or
real estate
on on these platforms anymore so we
started rumble in 2013 to really bring
back that fairness and really help that
small creator get access to those tools
get access to the monetization get
access to everything that those mcns
were giving creators access to
um and we built a pretty good business
in 2013 and it it was a good business
all the way up until uh 2020 and then it
became a really good business in 2000
and i would say starting in 2018 and
ford it became a really really good
business
um by 2020
everything hits the fan
it was
it was like 11 o'clock at night in the
middle of the summer and i remember a
congressman signing up to our to our
site and i was like holy [ __ ] like why
is a congressman
uh signing up to rumble like um this
being a canadian a canadian video
platform that was that was a pretty big
deal
um and uh i remember going to my
colleague and saying hey uh is this real
is this a real sign up and we looked at
it and we we think it was real it seemed
like it was real uh and a week later i'm
on the phone with this congressman and
he asks me a simple simple question
if i put my content on rumble will i be
able to find it in search if i search my
name
and we're like yeah that seems pretty
standard
it should come up in our search if
someone searches for you and he's like
well that's not happening anywhere else
on the internet it's not happening on
youtube so i i'm gonna bring it over to
to rumble within three months
less than that two months he accumulates
over 300 000 subscribers on rumble and
in the very same period over five
actually a longer period five years on
being on youtube he only had 10 000
subscribers
so you can kind of see how
that happened um and when that did
happened and everybody noticed
everything hit the fan everyone started
hearing about rumble people were like
growing faster on rumble the message
went out this congressman was on tv
telling everybody go to rumble
um we should tell you i know who the
answer is but we should tell people who
the congressman was
it was congressman devin nunes yeah um
he was uh he was the very first person
um in in the political spirit to come
onto rumble and
realized this problem that was happening
and uh when it did happen he was out on
tv letting everybody know that hey like
i'm growing faster on rumble and i'm
getting more views on rumble than i am
getting on youtube
and it wasn't long after that until
everybody started following and uh
jumping on a rumble and it took us to
we're 2021 now and in august we saw the
largest month we've ever seen on our
platform a tremendous amount of growth
from where we were six months ago seven
eight months ago
the largest single growth in a single
month was in august um and uh we haven't
looked back since and it's been
super exciting we we you know we did the
the merger and i want to call it a
merger well it's not really an
acquisition and i think we should really
you know explore that a little bit more
but the merger with you and uh becoming
partners with you and us off is uh is
the the next major moment in this
business and i and i'm super excited to
to uh to be here with you
and talk through this so before we get
into that stuff can you just tell people
a little bit about what you actually
have built like when people think oh
you're trying to compete with youtube or
you're trying to compete with amazon aws
like these sound like impossible feats
and you know as well as i like i went
into enough boardrooms to tell people
what we were doing with locals and
they're just like no the big boys exist
like accept it and move on
yeah and this is really like looking
under the hood and it's really important
it's a great question so one of the
things we did is we did when we built
rumble we built it the old-fashioned way
like i said i've been in this for two
decades i've been working off bare metal
in my own servers since the day i
started in
2001 or two or whatever it was
and i never really did it any other way
all these fancy words cloud and aws and
amazon i never subscribed to that and
when we started rumble we we put in our
own servers we put in use our own bare
metal and we built out our own
infrastructure from the ground up and we
didn't look back and how we did that
and you know it wasn't something that i
thought was necessarily
it wasn't like hey we need to do this
because we need to compete against them
it was like hey we need to do this
because it's going to save us costs it's
better it's just you know we own
everything it's uh we don't want to give
anybody access to that data we want to
make sure that's all under our hood and
not under someone else's hood and that's
kind of why we did it and you know you
come to 2020 in 2019 2020 and 2021
it ends up being a real real good
decision but that's not to say that we
didn't look into the future a little bit
with it when we started rumble we saw
rumble as like two things and one was to
compete aggressively against youtube and
the video platform as much as possible
and but if we successfully do that it
means that we'll now have the scale to
go really compete
against all these incumbent cloud
services remember
um you when you look at uh
at google in google cloud what do they
have that makes their infrastructure so
large youtube when you look at amazon
aws what do they have that makes their
infrastructure really large it's
amazon.com and twitch when you look at
microsoft azure you you look at xbox you
look at these things that really allow
them to have real competitive advantage
on the infrastructure side when you look
at rumble and now that rumble's become a
formidable size
we now have
um that that advantage to really offer a
cloud services really offer a new rail
and
you know after what we've seen in the
last year that new rail is really really
significantly needed as much as rumble
is needed as a video platform i actually
believe that the actual rail the cloud
the the infrastructure the service is
really really needed
for
the entire internet the free and open
internet is under attack and we need to
provide the rail as a common carrier as
close to a common carrier as possible
for for everyone else out there all the
other businesses
all the other you know churches
everything universities it's it kind of
spreads into every sector out there and
we really want to provide that
infrastructure so i'm sure many people
are watching this going so let me get
this straight if parlor let's say had
been on rumble infrastructure using
rumble infrastructure after january 6th
would parlor still be here right now
absolutely
rumble's still around um
right
i think that's a testament to
to where we are and what we're doing uh
rumble rumbles around and uh rumble will
be around and we're gonna continue to
build that rail and build that new
economy for for everyone not just for
rumble.com and locals but for everyone
and let me get this straight chris our
policy is that people can basically say
what they want and we're not going to
decide who the winners or losers are and
if maybe somebody broke the laws of the
united states they have a bigger problem
than chris and dave is that could we be
doing something so radical like that
yeah
you know i think that the best way to
look at it is that we got to get to
becoming a com as close to a common
carrier as possible we're not a
publisher we don't want to get an
editorial control we want to tell people
what they can or can't say if you're
having an argument at the dinner table
why can't you have that argument when
you're online if you're having a
discussion or having an opinion
why can't that be online this is the
free and open internet as free as your
dinner table there's no difference in my
mind and there shouldn't be and what
we've seen happen in the last 10 years
on the internet is this huge tilting to
kind of shut everybody up regardless of
of your political views they just every
they want to shut down the conversation
that we all have at our dinner tables
and that's just
it boggles my mind because when you look
back 10 15 years ago and you look at
these incumbent platforms they were all
preaching the free and open internet i
even think i saw twitter
uh twitter verified or twitter i'm not
sure twitter policy say that they want a
free and open internet in in nigeria and
like
where is that in the rest of the world
like right
they're still pretending they want a
free and open internet but it really is
not and i think that you know us
building the rails to that and really
providing an
open communication platform like rumble
are
are small pieces but but important
pieces to to making sure the internet
stays free and stays open all right i'm
dave rubin we are on location in miami
with miami mayor francis suarez
mr mayor first off
the shirt matches the shoes matches the
socks you are living
in the synthwave future that was
promised to us in the 80s huh that's
right that's right this is miami for you
know it's miami style this is absolutely
definitely miami style i mean i guess
the best way to start this off is that
this place is just blowing up you you
got to be kind of feeling good about
life and the world and what you're doing
yeah the easiest question ever been
asked to you before it's the most common
that's yeah
yeah no it really is i think a
generational opportunity a generational
moment miami was always a great place i
mean pre this sort of tech boom uh we
were growing significantly
we're not a very you know we're not a
well-kept secret uh but i think what is
happening now is
order of magnitudes different right
you're now creating a kind of ecosystem
and economy that's really going to
propel our city into the future the
world is changing it's changing at a at
a pace of disruption that we've never
seen before and we're talking about this
a little bit off-camera you know
cities just don't get it oftentimes they
don't understand that uh things are
changing and they're changing
permanently and they have to adapt
quickly when did you get it i mean did
you know about this sort of shift before
you were elected in 2017 or did this
just happen so i was actually elected in
2009 to the council as a councilman and
for about 10 years we were trying to
create this technological ecosystem i
you know almost young i'm a young
elected official for for a major city
i'm 43.
i was 32 at the time and i realized that
i was a first generation with a with a
smartphone i was the first generation uh
with laptops uh cell phones and and and
you realize that
our world is more and more engulfed by
technological tools i now have a
seven-year-old and a three-year-old and
my three-year-old just the other night
was telling me dad let's take a selfie
with her with her with her you know we
call it in spanish with her with her
pacifier you know she's taking a selfie
with me so three years old
so you realize cameras and pacifiers
that's uh and it's on its way it's
coming it's coming yeah but you know it
you know you realize that this world is
is becoming more and more tech focused
and cities have two options they can
either embrace that reality or they can
ignore it to their to their apparel to
the peril of their residents were you
worried at all that the people were
going to come from san francisco and
bring all of the bad policies and ideas
that basically wrecked silicon valley
and wrecked san francisco i hear the
worry a lot i actually don't worry and
i'll tell you why um you know my family
unfortunately was exiled from a
communist country in cuba
and i don't see people you know getting
on rafts and trying to go back to cuba
you know what i mean it's just not the
people that come here to miami are
traumatized they're traumatized by
governments that don't work by policies
that don't work and frankly you know the
decision to leave a particular city is a
very difficult decision particularly
when you have a family and to uproot
your family and say i'm going somewhere
else that is not easy
and so for me i find it very hard to
believe that anyone's going to make that
very difficult decision basically
trauma-based right to come to a new city
and then create the same policies that
created the conditions for them to want
to leave in the first place what kind of
chaos has it caused in the last year
being here i mean real estate prices are
bananas rents are going crazy these are
all good set of problems but it must be
a lot for you to just have to manage you
know what's interesting uh the real
estate prices are bananas in homes that
are on the water like this home you know
what i mean but uh we're competitively
speaking incredibly affordable so for
example in downtown miami the urban core
uh you can get a one bedroom apartment
in an unsubsidized like not affordable
housing or anything like that uh
building brand new fourteen hundred
fifty dollars in manhattan it's thirty
seven hundred dollars in san francisco
it's thirty seven hundred dollars so
you're talking about a three to one
differential that hasn't changed uh from
one day to the next and so and then you
know we're building a ton of affordable
housing uh we have the ability to build
supply which cities like san francisco
the bay area oftentimes and new york
can't do because new york is sort of
overbuilt and san francisco has
restricted their ability to build so uh
so we have the ability to remain
competitive for decades into the future
which i think is a huge competitive
advantage for our city
so i think when most people think of
conservatives they think of some kind of
old white guy sitting in a smoking room
and you know flipping through the wall
street journal or something like that
you're a conservative it seems to me
that you're sort of what the future of
conservatism is what does that actually
mean to you like what are your kind of
guiding principles you know i grew up uh
i was born in 1977 so i grew up sort of
in the 80s 76 years you're a young buck
there you go
my dad was mayor in 1985 of miami and i
grew up sort of in the reagan years so
for me sort of being a reagan republican
was someone that was strong on national
defense um you know for me i believe in
having a balanced budget even though
that's something that our federal
government has not been able to do for a
long time are you guys balanced here we
are we actually have a surplus we have a
150 million surplus in the city of miami
we have the second highest bond rating
we've ever had in the highest we've ever
had in the history under my leadership
so that's a double a plus so
you know i believe in fiscal
responsibility for governments i think
government should live within their
means uh i think that uh you know
government should be there to facilitate
not obstruct and oftentimes uh they are
obstructionist uh you know i but as a
conservative i also and as a young
person and someone who sees even young
conservatives uh and and and and young
liberals come up concerned about the
environment so i think that's something
that you know we have to have a better
conversation on immigration is another
issue that you know we're a city of
immigrants uh we're a country of
immigrants you know and that's a a you
know another issue i think we need to
have a healthier conversation on than
the one that we're having right now
in the sort of national landscape yeah
where does uh the bitcoin stuff fit in
this new future conservative
mecca that we've got going well i think
just did the big conference yeah we just
did the biggest the largest bitcoin
conference in in the world we also had
ftx which is a large a crypto trading
platform out of hong kong uh named the
uh the arena where the miami heat plate
200 million dollar naming deal we had
blockchain.com headquarter in the city
of miami 300 jobs and etoro which is
don't forget locals.com moved here and
locals.com as well and etoro as well so
i mean we've had a ton of of of crypto
uh companies moving over here in
blockchain and bitcoin companies moving
over here because we believe we were
sort of the david in this david and
goliath story right yeah but we believe
that uh to be uh sort of to have that
transformational moment we had to step
outside of the conventional box and i
thought that bitcoin and crypto was our
way of doing that uh you know we're the
first city in the world uh sort of the
first city in the united states second
city in the world to put to satoshi's
white paper on our website
uh you know we're the first city in the
world to begin the process of allowing
our employees to get paid in bitcoin uh
of allowing uh do you get do you get all
of it or is it just like you have good
people around you like because some of
the tech stuff the high-end high-level
tech stuff is a lot no i get it i get it
i get it because i sort of finance
background my dad was an engineer uh is
an engineer my grandfather was an
engineer as well
so i get the mathematics behind it i get
the principle behind that i was actually
part of the florida blockchain
foundation when it began and i'm
actually part of the florida blockchain
task force named by the cfo of florida
uh to promulgate uh state regulations
and laws uh to hope hopefully to
continue to bring crypto to miami so
it's into florida do you have other
mayors in either in florida or in the
rest of the country that are kind of
pissed they're kind of jealous like this
guy's making it happen and we're not
either because we're handicapped by our
own state governments or whatever it
might be you know the ones that probably
would be pissed are not calling you know
i think i think they feel like they're
yeah i can't speak for them they may
feel like they're boxing they may
believe some of the policies that their
their cities are promulgating that i
think are are not good for their cities
but i can tell you i've gotten a ton of
mayors that call me from across the
country uh and and chambers of commerce
from across the country that call me and
say hey how do we replicate what you're
doing down there and for us it's you
know there are some things that are hard
to replicate you know miami's kind of
hard to replicate but there are other
things that i think are very basic you
know for us we have basically our
formula for success is three things keep
taxes as low as humanly possible uh
while other cities defund police we're
investing in our police and we have the
highest a number of police officers ever
so public safety is incredibly important
to us it's something that we sell being
one of the safest big cities in america
and the third thing is we focus on
quality of life we know the fundamental
truth that nobody can live yesterday
again
so the most important decision that we
all make in our lives is where we are
this very moment where we're going to be
tomorrow we're going to be the day after
and if you create the kind of city that
really respects that decision
for example we have 555 homeless in the
city of miami we want to get to
functional zero which means we want to
be one of the first big cities in
america not to have any homeless i mean
i've been here for five days i have not
seen one homeless person i come from la
it's very very different it's very
different and i think uh you know we've
done a variety of things over a number
of years to get to that point um and we
want to get to zero if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about tech instead of
non-stop yelling check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell